- Whether Clubhouse is
huge in a year or not,
the time you spend here right now
while it's hot is valuable.
Everything eventually goes away.
It's about maximizing attention
and building reputation and
community while it's hot.
If you have a question,
please feel free to raise your hand.
Let's get some questions going.
- [Slovenian Man] Hello Gary, how are you?
- I'm well. Where are you from my friend?
- [Slovenian Man] From Slovenia.
- Very nice. How can I help you?
- [Slovenian Man] So, three years ago
we started a business from small country
and now we are selling all over in Europe.
So we are making around 50 millions,
so we are a selling through
Facebook ads and Instagram
and we want to build more brand
so we are doing a lot
of Instagram (inaudible)
and how can we make brands
to make more growth?
- So you're trying to
build more brand instead
of sales DNA, right?
- [Slovenian Man] Yes, yes, yes.
- So, you know, it's about content, right?
You have to make content,
whether it's influencers,
whether it's starting Clubhouse chats,
there's such a big difference
between building brand and building sales.
And so what you need to focus
on is brand content, right?
You need to focus on
actually making videos
and pictures that build
awareness and make them hear
of your product,
not just click and buy your product.
So I think influence is a good play,
I think Tik Tok is a huge play in Europe.
So I would get very aggressive
with content on Tik
Tok, where your website
or wherever you're trying to
convert is in your profile.
I think YouTube pre-roll
ads that are brand,
not sales focused that are very targeted
is a very strong play.
I think starting a podcast
Those would be the places
I would look my friend.
- [Slovenian Man] Thank you,
Gray, very much for your help.
- You're welcome my friend. Good luck.
Dylan.
- [Dylan] Hey, what's going on man?
- Life is good. And you?
- [Dylan] It's going
great, it's going great.
It's a pleasure, thanks
for bringing me up here.
Quick question for you.
So in a world where, you know,
a degree still a gatekeeper
of some sorts and specific
kind of like businesses,
what would you recommend
for people who are still pursuing it
but don't have the degree yet?
So let me give you some context.
So I own a company called (inaudible),
it's a sports psychology company.
I actually know Dustin
'cause I worked with him
and just, you know, we talked some time
so I'm still in school, but
the context that it brings
to the table is that I'm
a former national champion
(inaudible) number one in Canada
and top 40 in the world
traveled everywhere competing,
representing as a national
concatenate and all that.
And along the way
I developed a sports psychology
program based off those
you know, what I learned in the industry
and want to learn just from
being an athlete and, you know
I'm in school now pursuing the degree
but I'm not there yet.
And that's, you know,
made a lot of progress
in terms of working with UFC
fighters and football players
and you know, some of
the best in the world.
But I still find sometimes
that when I'm speaking with people
there's still a little bit
of (inaudible), you know
have you had your master's yet?
Yes or no.
And I'm just wondering, you know,
(both chattering)
- Two things;
Never sell the unsellable.
So if you walk into a
meeting where you're trying
to convince somebody to work
with you and they hope on that
you convert it into a friendship
karma acquaintance meeting,
not a potential client meeting
and you potentially even
cut the meeting short
and then you move on to the next.
I mean, you are literally
talking about millions
of people that could
potentially be your clients
and you're over focusing
on the nos instead
of spending your time, finding the yeses.
And as you know, I would argue
that all the conversations
you've had on a bad day,
it's 50-50 if people give
a fuck versus don't, right?
(indistinct chattering)
- I think so too
which is why I was saying
on a bad day, right?
So to me, this is a non-conversation
there's too many people
that are willing to work
with you without the bullshit paper
as a justification that
you dwelling on it,
even this question was a bad use
of time already to that theory.
I've sold things that nobody
believes in my whole life.
I need to have a website,
I'm selling New Zealand,
Spanish and Australian wine,
I believe in Google ad-words
versus direct mail and print,
I believe in this YouTube show,
I believe in Twitter,
I believe in Instagram,
I believe in social
media, I believe in voice,
I believe in podcasts,
my whole life I've been
selling quote unquote
things that nobody
believes in, sports cards,
everybody literally laughed
at me three years ago.
Right Dylan?
I don't spend time trying to convince.
Dylan don't spend time trying to convince.
Oh, that's a non-starter for you?
It was really nice to meet you
Tyrone, Sally, Ricky, Thompson, move on.
- [Dylan] Yeah, right.
- Like, right?
Like what's the punchline here
like convincing the unconvincing
unconventional is a waste
of your time.
I would get to it early
and not in like a dick
way where you're like, hey
do you give a shit about this?
Like somewhere in the
first five 10 minutes
of whatever time you're committing
get a sense of that's a roadblock
and if it is, I would
start a referral business
and say, Hey, you should
talk to my homie Sarah.
She's incredible.
She is actually certified.
The end.
- [Dylan] Yeah, you're right.
And I think what I do so
far is I've been listening
to a lot of what you've been talking
about over the last couple of years.
So what I do is I used
this stuff for free, right?
And I think, you know, I can credit-
- Yeah, but I'll be,
first of all, I love that, and thank you,
but I really want you to get home on
don't do something for free to somebody
'cause they don't validate you
'cause you don't have a degree.
Like now you're just trying
to convince somebody.
Don't convince anybody, Dylan.
- [Dylan] All right. Thank you.
- You got it brother.
- [Dylan] I appreciate it man.
- Of course.
I love when this stuff
helps other people as well.
Ross what's good?
Zane and Tan are my team
so we won't be talking to them,
we've talked to them enough.
What's good Ross?
- [Ross] Yeah, what's
good, man? (inaudible)
I'm running some campaigns
for some clients,
I'm the head of social agency in the UK
and from there were
very specific niche con
in the tech space and
you know, I've seen some
of the reports that we've been
getting from from last month
from December and they're
just not good at all.
And obviously I'm coming
to the mid, you know, recommendations
between page talks and
stuff, niche on LinkedIn.
But is there so space
for them to use Facebook?
I mean, they have some platforms
now have available there
but I've just kind of tied it in.
I'll just take the approach to LinkedIn
because I feel that's
where they need to be.
But you know, is there still a space
for Facebook and Instagram
for these type space clients?
- Is it a SAS business
or is it a B2B business?
- [Ross] It's like, (inaudible)
like data analytics.
Yeah. B2B, SAS businesses.
(both chattering)
- Yeah. No, I think they need
to be in Clubhouse, LinkedIn,
starting a podcast, maybe
doing some fishing on Twitter
on keywords where people are talking
and they need to engage as a brand
but general Facebook
and Instagram marketing
for B2B data analytics companies
is not a best use of strategy.
- [Ross] It's a no go,
so just completely (inaudible)
that completely because some
of the reports and some
of the results I've seen
from their Facebook stuff
is just so poor so...
- Yeah. You don't have
the targeting capabilities
or the audience psychology
to convert business results
in that environment.
If you're an SAP or
Salesforce, there's Oracle
there's a brand rationale
to be in those platforms.
But from a short-term business results
you're talking LinkedIn and
becoming an original media
company, podcasts, host Clubhouse rooms,
you know, very narrow niche it like that.
- [Ross] Sounds good.
(indistinct chattering)
- [Ross] But that set me
on track for my career
so I just wanted
(both chattering)
- [Ross] It was a big help.
- Two things for you Ross,
one, I've decided recently
somewhere in the next decade
I'm going to write Jab,
Jab, Jab, Left Hook
and then number two, VaynerMedia
London's growing rapidly
so keep that in mind.
(indistinct chattering)
- Hello Vanessa.
- [Vanessa] Hello Gary, first
of all, sorry for my English,
I'm Portuguese and my
English is not perfect.
- Your English is much
better than my Portuguese
so it's an honor.
- [Vanessa] And I want to say
that I'm a true fan of you,
I love your words, I love
what you say, your thoughts
and here it was a surprise
for me to be here.
I'm new in this platform.
I just wanted to ask, what
do you think of Clubhouse
do you think it will achieve a level
as Instagram or Facebook?
- I think Clubhouse is incredible.
And the concept of what
we're doing here is human.
It's what people do in real life.
They hang out in halls of
conferences at dinner tables.
So I'm very bullish on this format.
The thing that's going to play
out is, is this a feature
or is this a platform?
So I think Twitter's already
testing a competitor.
I predict that Facebook and Instagram
are gonna create this as a feature.
Most people have their
audiences on those platforms
and will have their
own self-esteem wrapped
up in the fact that when they go
into a talk on Instagram,
there's 2000 people in it
and when they go to Clubhouse,
if they start a room there's eight,
where they don't even have an invite.
So Vanessa I think Clubhouse
has incredible long-term upside.
I also think that it might be a feature.
- [Vanessa] Okay.
- All right.
- [Vanessa] Okay. Thank you.
- You're welcome.
But Vanessa, if you're
asking the question,
and this is for everybody
here, from the perspective of
is this worth your time
to spend time here?
Most people don't understand
that question well,
let me explain.
Right now, this has a lot of attention,
it has a lot of very intriguing
people in the community.
It's a good use of your time.
Whether Clubhouse is huge in a year
or not the time you spend here right now
while it's hot is valuable.
And most people worry about it going away.
Everything eventually goes away.
It's about maximizing attention
and building reputation and
community while its hot.
- [Vanessa] Yeah. Yeah.
- Got it?
- [Vanessa] Yeah. Got it.
- Cool.
- [Vanessa] Thank you.
- You're welcome. Bye-bye.
Hi Mae, or Mae, how do you pronounce it?
- [Mae] Hey Gary, good morning. It's Mae.
- Mae, real pleasure.
- [Mae] Pleasure is entirely
on this side of the phone.
I am a long-time listener,
long-time disciple
and I'm a little giddy right now.
- Thank you.
- [Mae] So, I am coming from
an immense place of gratitude.
The amount of premium
content you've delivered
over the years is incalculable.
And everyone here right now
in this room is valuable.
I'll keep it short.
I've known to be a bit
loquacious, so I'll keep it tight.
- Do your thing Mae.
- Gary, I was a... you know
what? I should change that.
I am a internal corporate planner
and was unfortunately laid
off early in the pandemic from my dreams.
I landed an internal corporate position
at a biotech firm in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
We were doing brilliant
things in the event space
with some pretty healthy budgets.
So as you can imagine, I was
able to travel the country,
travel the world and deliver
some stellar programs.
Unfortunately, I was laid off
and I understand that decision.
And after throwing about two weeks
of a deep pity party for myself
and for what my industry was
suffering, I took the leap
and Gary, you're a big, big part of this.
I started a small boutique
virtual events firm
because I saw the need
to pivot immediately.
And so really kind of
capitalized on that white space
that dead time where we were
all just kind of shell shocked
and super lean, super, super lean,
hadn't done any paid advertising,
really leveraged all of your tools,
utilizing social, LinkedIn, Facebook.
And it's a miracle story
but somehow Howard
Stern the admin found me
on Instagram and long, long story short,
I designed, produced and
delivered Howard Stern's first
ever virtual holiday party.
- That's amazing, good for you.
- [Mae] It's brilliant
and I offered that up,
not as a braggadocious (inaudible)
more of a nibble of hope
for anyone out there.
- The internet is a
platform of opportunity,
you know, a period and the story.
(indistinct chattering)
- Mae, is there anything
I can answer for you?
- [Mae] Yes. Let me bring it home.
I feel like this miracle
story is just that
and it is almost bringing to life
everything that you preach.
I mean, it truly is.
I worked quietly, I worked patiently,
I didn't tell anyone what was
happening during the summer
and then it paid off.
I am curious if there is a way I feel
like I'm not leveraging the story
because I feel like I'm
sitting on something here-
- You just need to do what
you did the first time.
You need to put out
content around the story.
You need to go to LinkedIn right now
and I don't know if you're a good writer
and write, you know, six paragraphs of
let me tell you a story
of a COVID layoff, right?
You need to-
- You know what Gary, I did.
I actually posted, and
again, you will find that you
about being candid and vulnerable,
documenting the process.
I posted a story and I titled
it, a series of events.
- I love that title.
Mae, let me tell you something,
do you know how many
times I've told the world
about my lemonade stands
and sports cards story?
- [Mae] I know because
I've heard them a lot.
- Right, so I think where
you might be getting caught
and a lot of people get caught
is I think you need to tell the story
in written video and audio form
every day, three times a day
for the next nine 98 days.
DM seven... you got it.
DM every single events podcast,
even if they have 41 listeners
and go on for 30 minutes
and tell the story
and ask them for the video
footage and then chop it up
and then post it on your Instagram.
Write another LinkedIn article
more around being laid off during COVID
'cause that's more of a title
that will get organic reach.
Like this is just reps.
What you basically just
said to me is Gary...
Right now you just said to me,
Gary, I have not been
eating well my whole life
and Thursday I ate clean and worked out.
I'm like, that's good, Mae.
Now let's do it for the
rest of our fucking life.
- [Mae] For sure.
- Got it?
- [Mae] Absolutely. Got it.
- Cool.
- [Mae] For sure.
- Have a great day.
- [Mae] For sure. Gary, thank you.
Have a great day, everyone.
- Kayla, how are you?
- [Kayla] Hi Gary, good morning.
I'm doing well, how are you?
- I'm well, thank you.
- [Kayla] Thanks for having me.
- Of course.
- [Kayla] My question is
around imposter syndrome
and being a young professional
and wanting to pivot my career.
I'm in sales and wanting to pivot
into a more marketing realm
and just how to combat imposter syndrome.
- By realizing that imposter
syndrome is actually
just a fancy word for insecurity.
- [Kayla] Yeah.
- Like, and then saying, I'm insecure
because these life events,
this is how my mom or dad rolled,
this is what happened to me at 12,
this is my DNA 'cause I'm like my grandma
and then saying, cool, that's life, karma,
nobody's better than me.
I'm just authentically candid of like
I want to be in marketing,
I want to take my at-bats.
When somebody says no
to me, that's not bad,
it's actually understandable,
I'm gonna try 113 times,
somebody is eventually going to say yes
and then I'm going to try.
When I'm trying, Oh crap
this company didn't set me up
for success, I quit or they fired me,
and that also doesn't
mean I suck or I can't,
I just need to go back to the well
cause that's only one example
of me getting out that (inaudible).
Self-esteem and self-awareness
are the two biggest things
that I actually speak about
in a million different ways.
And so Kayla literally imposter syndrome-
- [Kayla] Gary?
- Yep?
Hello?
- [Kayla] Yes, I'm here.
- Oh good, so imposter syndrome
it's kind of like perfection, right?
It's an excuse and not a bad excuse,
it's a packaging, it's a merchandising
to make something palpable.
You just have to recognize
that you have insecurities securities
about this jump and that's super okay.
I have insecurities about
being on top of tall buildings,
I had insecurities of
kissing girls in high school.
Like everybody has insecurities, right?
And so that's cool, but
it's not gonna change
whether it's gonna be good
or bad or indifferent.
What it is going to do
is make you not do it.
And you've got to realize
much like swimming
or riding a bike or kissing someone
or making love for the first time
or all the things that we
all go through in life.
We make them scary in our head
and then they're not
scary after you do it.
- [Kayla] Awesome, thank you.
- Does that make sense, Kayla?
- Yes, it does.
- Like, do you have a
sense like does that land?
Like you're like, yep.
Like that should like, do you get that?
- [Kayla] I do, because I definitely think
it's rooted in insecurity.
- Right. And so somebody
told like, you know
I don't want to go into like cry session
but like it, you know,
maybe somebody told you
your whole life that
you weren't good enough
or you couldn't maybe
society, maybe your mom,
you know, that's just life that
happens to a lot of people.
That's the reality of it.
But you have to realize,
and for everybody here
all 2000 of you, right?
This is very important.
If you think your shit
or you're not good enough, or you can't
that was somebody else
putting that in your mind.
Like, it's actually
just genuinely not true.
Now that doesn't mean you can do anything
but you need to try 'cause
you actually don't know.
You know what I mean?
- [Kayla] Hi Gary.
Yes, sorry, I definitely
agree a thousand percent,
it's just kinda going deep into-
- Like what's the worst
that can happen, Kayla?
They say, no, you're not good enough.
So you go to the next person.
It's no different than Dylan earlier.
- [Kayla] Right, right.
Thank you, I appreciate that.
- I hope you have a great day and listen,
we really, really, really have to get
into a place where we
look at no, as a motivator
not as a indicator to us not being good.
(inaudible).
- [Simon] Hello Gary.
- How are you, my friend?
How do you pronounce your name my friend?
- [Simon] Shimon is the
original pronunciation,
I go by Simon.
- Simon, got it. Simon,
it's a real pleasure.
- [Simon] Yeah. It's
a pleasure to be here.
I really appreciate you having me.
I very much look up to you.
I am immigrant from Poland as
well, actually, not Poland.
You know, we pretty much from
very similar region in Europe.
So I've been looking up into your story
and I'm very grateful that
I was able to follow it
and that I am able to follow it.
And then we have the internet
so I have a capability to follow it.
- Thank you.
- [Simon] So I had a chance
to be in the room with you.
I saw you at the Fairfax
conference when you were
with Tony Robbins, great experience.
But what I want to say, you know
we work with the ergonomics
design and how to,
pretty much position body
ergonomically at computer.
And I'm kind of going into many
different areas in my life.
We've been kind of grinding with my wife.
My wife is a physical therapist.
We've been doing that for many years now
and I guess my question as I go
(inaudible) too much of your time.
- No worries.
- [Simon] What's the best
way to approach gamers
and introduce the healthy lifestyle
and basically start to direct them
into the position that
they started thinking
about health outside of the gaming itself?
- That's smart.
I think that's actually
a really good idea.
A niche around health, like
physical health lifestyle
from an eating and exercise standpoint
for the gaming community
is a really good idea,
given that they sit all day.
It's content and reaching out,
it's producing videos,
audio, written words
on the 10 platforms that matter.
And then it's sending
direct messages to 10,000
you know, 10 platforms,
10,000 direct messages, right?
Make content for as many
platforms as you can
whether that's one or 10, preferably 10,
but that, you know, it
takes time and talent
and then reach out to people and say,
hey, I think you're incredible at Twitch
or I love your call of duty skills
or your 2Ks this or this,
that the other thing,
but I really think you
should check out this video
and maybe you send them
the best performing organic
YouTube video that you've put
out around the subject matter.
The whole world is based
on content and outreach and
distribution and awareness.
- [Simon] Yes I agree, I agree.
I've been reaching out much more right now
since our concept change,
since we've been going much
into office corporate economic factory
and I actually communicated
at some point with your HR people.
- That's awesome.
- [Simon] (inaudible) So
I couldn't get to you.
- That's awesome.
(indistinct chattering)
- Right.
So the fact that you got
the sky at VaynerMedia
who gets bombarded by my
fans 3000 times a day means
that you're well on your way,
just make a lot of content.
- [Simon] (inaudible) was
actually using my workstation
when he was here.
- That's awesome, that's awesome.
- [Simon] It was cool.
But anyway, I don't wanna-
- No worries, Simon real pleasure.
I wish you well.
Matt Mark, before I go to you real quick,
I need to say happy birthday
to my main man, Cesar,
who I just brought up
here, an incredible part
of our team Gary family, worked
with us for several years.
Caesar, what's good?
(indistinct chattering)
- I love it man.
Happy, happy birthday.
What is it, your 20th birthday?
- [Caesar] Yeah, I'm finally 20.
- What birthday is it actually for you?
- [Caesar] It's 37.
- Good for you brother.
How have you been, you good?
- [Caesar] I'm good, how
are you? how's everyone?
- Everyone's great, brother.
I just want to say happy birthday.
I have to go in four minutes
so I'm going to try and
get to Mark and Renee.
I love you. We'll talk soon.
(indistinct chattering)
- Mark.
- [Mark] Okay, cool.
Thanks for the opportunity.
(inaudible) Gary, love your content,
- Thank you.
- [Mark] (inaudible) four minutes
so I'm going to keep it quick.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] So you know, like
I'm a freelancer (inaudible),
work for the prescribed brand right now
and like, I'm thinking about
doing podcast or Clubhouse.
Like I would love to
have your perspective.
- You should do your podcast on Clubhouse.
I believe that Clubhouse is
rolling out a recording feature.
I'm going to do that.
I'm going to do my podcast
on Clubhouse interview one
person, let everybody listen
strip the audio and then
put it on my podcast.
- [Mark] Awesome. Thank you for that.
And one more question.
When are you coming to (inaudible)
because we were waiting for you, man?
- Brother, I would love to be there.
The way I travel is basically
two-fold my business
objectives for Vayner
X or when somebody puts
up the big six figure
bag to have me speak.
So hopefully one of those
two things will happen.
(indistinct chattering)
- All right brother, talk
to you soon, take care.
Renee.
- [Renee] I can't even say my
name in less than four minutes
so I've gotta make (inaudible).
- I love you.
- [Renee] Okay, so what we have
is pivoted wedding show,
producers for 30 years,
we were starting to pivot
to become digital marketers
before the pandemic that
pushed us over the edge.
We have found that since
we were business owners
and you know, working
for our own companies,
doing it, following you for seven years,
doing everything you were saying,
little mini (inaudible) we were.
And we were, you know
making it work in sale, pandemic came,
we had found out as we did
as we pivoted with our
marketing company, we found
that we are really best
suited to the fractional CMOs.
We can come back
with a whole list perspective
and we've got the age, we've
got the prowess, we get it.
We come in and we see things
from cracks and crevices.
And how do we attract that client?
- LinkedIn content to
your face falls off Renee.
Like literally unlimited content that says
do you need a fractional CMO?
Another article is, do you
know what a fractional CMO is?
Another one that's titled like 13 ideas to
help your marketing this year
and it's just a good piece
of content at the bottom,
it says, are you looking
for fractional CMO?
This is what we do.
Just go all in on that, I
think it's a real space.
- [Renee] It is. It really is
'cause people say to us, Oh we
want more leads, more leads.
We go and find out if
we can fill the funnel
all fricking day.
And guess what (inaudible), we did a video
on YouTube called, do
you have a sales funnel
or a sales calendar?
- Correct.
- [Renee] People are
moving all left and right.
- LinkedIn is your Holy grail
and host some rooms in here.
Literally call it fractional CMO life
and 40 people will show up
because that's how Clubhouse works.
So content in business places
preferably LinkedIn and Clubhouse.
- [Renee] You got it. Thank you so much-
- You got it, take care.
Everybody, I'm sorry, a
little bit short this morning,
I was gonna go on at 8:30,
which is the time I'm targeting to go
on with these tea with Gary Vs.
Gotta go to a meeting right
now, but a couple things.
One, if you take a
screenshot of this right now
and hit me up on Twitter with
a question in written form
I will try to answer some
while I'm in meetings on zoom all day.
Number two, if you have a question
and you want to have me
answer it on my social medias,
video yourself right now
asking your question,
posted on Twitter with
the hashtag ask Gary V,
my team will look for good questions
and then I'll answer some
and you may show up on my
Instagram where I'll tag you
and you end up with a hundred
to 5,000 new followers.
So those are the two
things that I can continue
this conversation with
based on my time schedule.
I hope you enjoyed it.
I would love for you
to also use the hashtag
ask Gary V or tea with Gary
V, both work for me on Twitter
and give me some feedback on this format
and I hope you have a
beautiful, beautiful Wednesday.
Cheers. Thank you. Bye-bye.
Hey guys, thanks for watching
my little session here
on Clubhouse, trying some
different stuff with content.
I hope some of those questions
brought you some value.
I really liked the don't
sell to the unsellable.
So many of you are wasting so
much time trying to convince
instead of going to the next person,
who's already interested.
Huge waste of time,
content, content, content
content, content, content,
and many other tidbits.
I hope you enjoyed it. See you.
YouTube watch what's up, it's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also want to ask you
please subscribe because my
commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to
explode stories, polls,
more content, more engagement,
more surprise and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it
and I hope I see you soon.